our annual giving show so we thought
we'd do something fun we got a couple of
hundred people or so in the lobby and uh
we ordered pizza for all of you so Pizza
just got here they look hungry and now
happy you need to go pay oh I'm paying
the pizza delivery okay I'll be right
back guys hold on go go pay the pizza go
pay the pizza George and take care of
that what's your name Marissa did you
bring me any cauliflower crust wasn't on
the order I'm just kidding it's it's
totally fine well what's the bill today
let me see if I can dig into these
little skinny jeans yeah I
got2 ,000 is that
okay yeah that's fine can that's for you
Merry Christmas are you serious I'm dead
serious oh my God thank you so much
what's the biggest tip you've ever
gotten um probably 170 bucks well now
it's a thousand you can tell the story
thank you so much we got you we're going
to get you taken care of with Financial
Peace University every dollar our
budgeting tool everything we can throw
at you from this bookstore it's on us
today